-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Tracy Morgan.
You got a giant honor recently.
You were honored by
the Friars Club
as their Icon,
their Icon Award?
This has been given out to
people like
Billy Crystal, Martin Scorsese,
Robert de Niro, Tony Bennett.
Quite a list.
-Yeah, man.
Douglas Fairbanks Jr.
They weren't even talking
back then.
-Yeah.
-And I got one.
I'm like, y'all sure y'all
giving it to the right person?
They gave me a Friars Club --
I'm the first black recipient
to get this award.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's fantastic.
-First Black recipient.
Think about that.
You think about that,
the first Black recipient
to receive an Icon
Friars Club Award.
So we can look back on this
and say,
I am the first, like,
Friars Club member
to have a bigger [bleep]
than Milton Berle.
[ Laughter ]
-That is what I'm gonna say
when I look back on it.
[ Laughter ]
-Very important.
-It's historic.
Now -- [ Laughing ]
Hey, I know there were
a lot of people there
to celebrate you, including
our new mayor, Mayor Adams,
who tends to get out to events.
-Yeah, he was there.
Giuliani was there.
De Blasio,
everybody was there, man.
The mayor was there.
I don't call him "Mayor Adams."
I call him "Eric."
-You call him Eric?
-That's my boy, yeah.
We went to high school together.
-You did? How was that?
-I sold him lunch tickets.
-You sold him lunch tickets?
-Especially when it was
fish and tater tots.
-[ Laughing ]
-He loved tater tots
and chocolate milk.
[ Laughing ]
-You were kind enough to
sell him your lunch ticket.
-Yeah, I love the mayor.
-That's great.
-That's my guy.
-I'm very happy to hear that.
-Mm-hmm.
-I want to ask about this.
Your daughter has taken to
the idea of doing stand-up.
-Yeah, that's my baby.
She just did it in front of
Radio City,
three jokes and told a story
in front of 500 people
at Radio City, and it was great.
She writes my material now.
-She writes your material?
-Yeah.
-What does she got?
She got anything you like?
-A lot of good stuff.
Like, the other day, she was
playing with her cousin,
and they were playing with
the Tonka Trucks,
and her cousin accidentally
hit her with a Tonka truck,
and she made him pay her $20.
[ Laughter ]
I said, "You're a chip
off the old block."
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, is it true --
we have Jabari Banks coming out.
He's so great in the new
"Bel-Air," playing --
-I don't like to talk
about that.
-Okay, 'cause you don't
like to talk about --
-Nah, I could have
got that role.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I could have got that role.
They did a background check.
Too much porno.
-Oh, really?
-I starred in too much
porno stuff.
-So it wasn't that you were
too old for the part,
it was just, you failed
the background check?
-Yeah, the background check.
-Yeah.
-That's such a bummer.
-I had the part!
[ Laughter ]
-They gave you the cast,
and then they did
the background check
and they took it away.
-Too much. No.
-That's so heartbreaking.
I'm so sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, what's the title,
"No Disrespect,"
how'd you come up with the title
for your show?
-'Cause I'mma say
a lot of stuff onstage,
and I don't mean to
disrespect anybody.
-Okay, so you'd like to
get that out front.
-There's a lot going on.
-Yeah, there's a lot going on.
-Between audience members
and comedians on there.
-Yeah.
-There's a lot going on now.
That's why I bring
a baseball bat onstage.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-I got a Louisville Slugger
for you.
This is not "attack
Tracy Morgan onstage" night.
-You've got a lot of shows
in Texas.
I think four or five dates
Have you done stand-up
in Texas before?
-Yeah, I've done it there, but
this is on a different level,
because of the recent
mass shooting there, man.
I just want to go there and show
some love to those people, man.
[ Applause ]
-That's really sweet.
-I love you, Texas.
It was horrible.
It was a horrible thing, and we
were all traumatized by it.
I just want to have
an opportunity to go there
and show my love
to those people.
-And I imagine when people go
and see Tracy Morgan,
the expectation is they're gonna
have a really good time,
and I can't imagine you'd do
anything but deliver.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Well, thank you so much
for being here, Tracy.
-I love you, Seth.
You know that.
-It's always an honor
to have you here.
-You guys, that's Tracy Morgan.
For tickets and information
about the "No Disrespect" tour,
which heads to Texas next month,
July 21st through the 24th,
you can go to TracyMorgan.com.
We'll be right back
with Jabari Banks.